اخر معاقل الروس في مقاطعه ميكولاج الساره
الاوكرانيا خالصا
انها ستريكه او ما تبقى منها تتحرر من
قبضه روسيا لطالما شكلت هذه المدينه حلقه
وسط المهمه بين مناطق شرق نيكولاج والشمال
خاشقجي
اليوم تخريقه اصوات النيران التي تسمع من
فينه لاخرى يقول لاكرانيون ان هذه المدينه
باتت تجسد خساره الاستراتيجيه لروسيا
اثار المعارك العنيفه لا تخطئها العين
بقايا عتاد ومركبات الروسيه تكشف ضراوه
المواجهات
انظروا الى ما خلفه الروس في مدينتنا هذا
هو السلام الروسي المزعوم اثناء وجودهم
كنا نعيش في اقبيه المدارس حياتنا كانت
صعبه
خلفت الحرب تبعات ثقيله اكثر من 13,000
كانوا يسكنون المدينه قبل الحرب لم يبقى
منهم سوى المئه في زمن الحرب يحرص
الاوكرانيون على ابرازيل تكاتفهم
عيشت دخول الروس الى ريفكا وخروجهم منها
نحن الان نتنفس الحريه ونحصل على مساعدات
عندما كان الرسول هنا لم نكن نستطيع السير
في الطرقات كانوا يعاملوننا بقسوه
كثير من الطرقات المحيطه بمنزل فيكتوريا
تحولت الى طرق للموت بسبب الالغام الروسيه
المغادره كانت البيوت تهتز على وقع
الياتهم قبل ذلك زرع الغاما في الجوار
ووضعوا قذائف في المنازل
ما ان استعيد تستهريكا حتى بدا الجيش
الاوكراني عمليه تفكيك الالغم يقول انه
فكك منذ بدايه الحرب اكثر من ثمانين الف
عبوه ناسفه في عموم البلاد تمرس ماديا
الجزيره رسمي ريفكا ميكو لايف